I had a very interesting exchange on
Twitter today with a younger person
about what you can read and what kind of
life to to live some very big picture
topics and it got me thinking about some
matters I've been reflecting on quite a
bit lately and that I think might be of
interest to other people so a little bit
of context here I mentioned that
yesterday was Thanksgiving here in the
United States and all I really did over
that time was I read some you know
fantasy literature I went and picked up
uh cat and and we came here had a nice
meal got to catch up on a lot of stuff
uh between me and Andy and and Kat and
then we watched Rick and Morty that we
ate some more food you know because it's
Thanksgiving and you snack on things
over time chatted a bit more and then
that was it for the day basically and so
this uh Tucker wrote me and said it's
nice to see well-read people such as
yourself making time to watch a season
of a cartoon and just hang out with
friends and family Here's the the real
meat it can seem impossible to pursue
being truly well read and also have time
for everything else do you have any
thoughts on that and my immediate
response was well yeah don't frame
things in terms of some vague and
unattainable goal of being truly well
read or having time for everything else
life involves trade-offs sacrifices and
prioritizing you can only do so much and
that's usually not a lot and I think
I'll talk about the being truly well
read
some other time I want to talk here
about the fact that we we can't do it
all that's impossible and it's as
impossible and ideal although not
structured in exactly the same way as
being truly well read whatever that is
going to mean so I do think that our
lives
um long before we even realize this is
the case are often very contingently
shaped by not only the choices that we
ourselves make oftentimes without you
know fully understanding the context and
the entire range of options and
background assumptions that are going
into those choices that we do from
childhood onward but they're also
structured by the choices that other
people make for us as well our parents
our teachers our you know uh coaches
mentors friend groups uh whoever else is
involved in structuring the basic uh
schedule you could say of Our Lives or
the unschedule right and so I think it's
really important for us particularly as
we move into adulthood and then you know
as we typically screw up quite a bit and
move into from Young adulthood into
middle age and then perhaps even into
old age that we we think very
consciously about the fact that we are
indeed making uh
orders of preference however you want to
think about it and there's a number of
philosophers out there I think who have
a great deal to contribute in this
respect you know if you think about
Aristotle and the notion of what gets
translated as moral choice or choice or
deliberate Choice
proiracis it literally means to choose
one thing in place of or rather than
another the stoics up until Epictetus
Define it as a choice before a choice
and then Epictetus made it the absolute
centerpiece of his his work in general
you know we are pro-i-racists we are are
ordering of preferences and choices and
commitments and one thing that we have
to keep in mind is we truly cannot have
it all and we can't even make decisions
on the basis of like laying everything
out in front of us and looking at each
thing rationally and fully and then
coming to a nice ordering that is
perfectly rational and would work not
just for us as individuals but for human
beings in general I mean we can do this
in very broad Strokes but we can't
actually do this
when we get down to all of the
particulars
and so we have to think about our
prioritizations are preferences are and
I would even use the word
sacrifices somebody also mentioned a
philosopher who thought quite a bit
about this was Mark Shaler who makes
um you know this this notion of
preference absolutely Central to his
ethics as well and you know we can find
orderings of our lives and activities
and the goods that we pursue and desire
and the evils that we want to avoid and
the relationships that we have and the
moral development that we want to
undergo all these things we can find
orderings that work for us for a while
but they may not be perfect for us for
our entire life and we have to be
willing to look at how other people are
doing things and saying oh no I don't
want to do things that way because look
at that person really mess messed up
their life you know they claim to be a
family man but they work too hard and
didn't have time this is sort of like
the plot of a lot of movies to go to
their children's recitals and they saw
the empty chair and they were so sad and
it ruined the relationship because I
don't want to be like that guy over
there and then we can also say oh that
person seems to have better priorities
than I do or we can look at our
priorities and be like well there's the
priorities that I say that I have and
then there's how I actually behave I'm
making all these cool plans for myself
that never get realized and I you know I
need to look at how I actually do indeed
behave and what it is that I think I
value or or you know show that I value
or prefer more so I think this is a
really important theme and I would like
to you know give a few words of
encouragement about this
drawn from I guess you could say not
just you know philosophical Reflections
but my own experiences with having many
many many times given the wrong things
priority and uh sometimes lucked out in
giving the right things priority so the
first thing is this this sort of stuff
is difficult right and so you shouldn't
feel like you're you know when you look
at other people's lives and the ways in
which they've got them ordered and the
activities they're pursuing you're
seeing it from the outside very often
even if it's a story about like Decline
and fall you're only getting a little
picture of it so you can't really judge
that effectively until you get to know
somebody what their you know structures
of priorities and what they're giving
their time to and what they're not
giving their time to how they really
work so you you don't have to feel too
bad about your own mistaken priorities
that you probably are you know engaged
in you might claim you're really about
you know study and the philosophical
life but you know you party a lot on the
weekends or something like that hey I've
been there you know sometimes you can
burn the proverbial candle at both ends
and sometimes you can't the other thing
you know what you devote yourself to
that that really is is up to you and you
can take counsel or advice or you know
even orders from other people but at
some point you're going to if it's not
something you really really identify
with you're gonna get tired of that and
you're gonna lose energy lose Steam not
not make as much progress as you'd like
it's got to be something that you can
buy into it's got to be reflective of
something within you and again that can
change over time there can be things
that you're not suited for doing in your
early 20s and by the time that you're
reaching the end of that decade you're
you're ready to do that you know there's
other things that you might find
yourself devoting a lot of time to and
getting a lot of value out of and then
things assume a different perspective
because of you know things you went
through life events lessons you've
learned books you've read and now you've
got to reframe those in a different way
maybe drop some things out and add some
new things in so another thing that I'll
say is you you literally cannot have at
all and the only ways in which people do
appear to be having it all you know
moving from as we say virtue to Virtue
or strength to strength or success to a
success there's always a lot of other
people in the background doing a lot of
the work that this person is you know
taking credit for and has been fortunate
enough to be in that position don't
judge yourself
and how you're doing based on what you
see other people who appear to be
successful doing until you actually
spend time with them and know them it's
enough if you make some progress in you
know reading books or exercising your
body to be more healthy or working on
your relationships or developing some
philosophical or spiritual practices
that you do that you find improve your
life that's that's good that's actually
doing something for yourself and if you
prioritize if you order your life to
provide those space and time and energy
and thought within your life you will
you will find like people have
throughout these centuries and Millennia
that you know you derive some reward
from it and it doesn't have to be you
know Earth shaking it doesn't have to be
insights all the time it doesn't have to
be benching 450 pounds or you know
squatting and doing this or any sort of
craziness like that in order for you to
have actually
achieved something
you can indeed make a lot of progress
but you know it requires attentiveness
it requires deliberately choosing these
things over and over and over again you
can't make a choice once or a plan or a
schedule and then it just falls into
place you have to keep on persevering in
that and that's tough and so you know I
I feel for all of you out there who are
trying to do that because I've been
there myself and I still fail at you
know setting up good priorities for
myself that I can stick to
consistently I fail myself day by day
week by week but you just keep working
at it and eventually you get a bit
better at it but you don't have to try
to do everything you shouldn't place
that pressure upon yourself the key if
you do have to do anything this is the
last bit of advice that I'll close on
you you want to develop a kind of
prudence or practical wisdom
in taking the stuff in your life
and figuring out how you're going to
organize and order it so that your
choices your commitments the habits that
you're building the habits that you're
destroying are actually leading you into
the kind of life that you want to live
so you can be yourself seeing a
reflection in your actions and choices
and judgments and relationships and
connections to other people of the
things that you say that you really
value and that is genuine Prudence or
practical wisdom as the Greeks called it
fronasis which is a really central part
of any virtue ethics so to to return
back to this you know instance of
Thanksgiving sometimes you actually do
need downtime you can't be rushing ahead
grinding away hustling all the time that
might be something that you do do give
preference or prioritization too because
you view that as as important for your
development but you also do need to have
some time for relaxation for
unstructured
downtime and enjoying yourself and
renewing and refreshing yourself and
when you do that you also want to avoid
falling into the Trap of trying to make
it be the best relaxation time or you
know the most productive down time that
you can have that's that's kind of a
mistake there so uh back to the central
point you actually can't have it all and
part of what we want to do is learn how
to make choices and commitments and
prioritizations and sacrifices the
things that we're going to say not for
me how to do that well and thoughtfully
and in ways that we can continually a
update and reflect upon and make better
I was almost going to say improve but I
don't want to get caught up in that
language of continual Improvement as a
matter of fact if you do good for a
while and then you kind of decline for a
while and then you find yourself you
know climbing back up that's okay and
that's perfectly normal too so you know
prioritization preferences commitments
choices habits all of these things we we
want them to be structured by Prudence
which we're not born with we have to
develop over time you probably don't
have enough of it I don't have enough of
it but we can certainly improve it over
time and we can
you know kind of take heart hopefully
in the fact that everybody else is
struggling with the same thing even if
they don't know it even if they present
themselves as not struggling with it
everybody is so you are I am and you
know just try to do it a little bit
better